welcome to episode 19 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with dr jeff
mcnary the chief medical officer at
rhythmia life advancement center in
costa rica
that's right the ayahuasca resort this
was actually the first episode i ever
filmed for the podcast back in april
i've been intrigued by ayahuasca for a
while although my gut instinct is it's
not a lot different than really
high-dose mushrooms
i mean high like seven grams but i could
be wrong i haven't tried it yet
the episode was interesting we covered
commonly asked questions about ayahuasca
what the ayahuasca experience at
rhythmia is like what kind of
afflictions hallucinogens like ayahuasca
can help
i would warn though if you have serious
mental health problems or are prone to
panic attacks sometimes high-dose
solution gins can make that
worse i'm a huge advocate for the
benefits of mushrooms and hallucinogens
for mental health
but if you are not in a good place
sometimes they can magnify that
so do your research if you decide to
delve into hallucinogens and don't be
silly or stupid about it
dr mcnary has worked in the mental
health field for over 25 years in la as
well as hawaii
he works mostly with patients who have
addictions and trauma although also
deals with people who suffer from acute
psychiatric conditions
he was the previous administrative
director of passages in malibu
a well-known drug and alcohol rehab
facility he's also managed and worked
within various medical arenas at the
ucla medical center
department of health in hawaii and
conducted therapy in psychiatric
hospitals as well as
a variety of outpatient settings dr jeff
is committed to bringing the ancient
healing tool of plant medicine
to the western world in a manner that's
safe regulated
and extremely effective i hope this
answers your ayahuasca questions
folks please remember to subscribe and
leave a review if you enjoy the episode
and would like to hear more
i'd like to thank optimal carnivore for
sponsoring this podcast
optimal carnivore makes a grass-fed
organ complex in a pill form
they take 100 percent freeze-dried
grass-fed grass-finished organs and use
gelatin capsules as the casing
so they're as healthy as you can get
other than fresh organs
they're free of hormones pesticides
antibiotics and gmos
if you know anything about my lion diet
it's ruminant meat salt and water
that's it i do eat other things than
steak though when i'm feeling it
liver sometimes and bone marrow i
generally tell people eat how you feel
don't force yourself to eat organs if
you don't want to
however if you are deficient in certain
vitamins this is how i would suggest you
get your vitamins
rather than taking the drugstore
versions that are filled with fillers
that aren't good for you
a lot of those are filled with soy and
corn and they probably aren't that
bioavailable
getting your vitamins from organs is the
most bioavailable way to do it
means you absorb the most that way organ
meats are some of the most nutrient
dense
foods on the planet visit amazon.com
optimal carnivore and use the code
michaela10 to receive 10 off of all of
their products
if you need vitamins and you take a
multivitamin or are considering taking
one
this is what i would recommend instead
[Music]
hi jeff welcome to the show thank you so
much for talking to me i'm
really interested in what you do cool
i'm so glad to be here i'm happy to
answer any questions you have
we're doing some exciting stuff down in
costa rica
yeah okay so i think we should probably
start with
what is rhythmia what is ayahuasca
great question so rhythmia is a place
that
is a medically licensed facility from
the costa rican ministry of health
and we're we're called a life
advancement center
and what it means is that people come
there for all different situations
whether it's
mental health issues or addiction or
pain
issues or any sort of life transition
stuff and they can go through our
program which is a week-long
and we have all these different
treatment modalities that help
support a person's own process and our
primary
modality is ayahuasca and so we use that
four nights a week
out of the the seven day stay
and there's tons of classes and
integration and all kinds of support
and the thing that makes rhythmia unique
from other facilities is that we have
a western sort of philosophy based also
with
an indigenous plant medicine community
so we have doctors and nurses and
therapists and all the kind of western
people
also with shamans and holistic healers
kind of combined
so we're looking we're looked at as sort
of a bridge between an indigenous
old world sort of remedy for healthcare
and then the things that
people are kind of used to from you know
hospitals and clinics and places like
that so
that's basically what rhythmia is and
i'm the chief medical officer
there and i've been there since the
beginning i'm i'm one of the founders
wow so how did you how did you come to
be like founding something like rhythmia
what's the back story there yeah it's
it's a wild story
so i started off studying medical
anthropology as an undergrad
and really loved it wanted to go to grad
school and get a phd in that
i got into berkeley decided to defer my
enrollment and
study at ucla and do med anthro research
for a year
that's when i saw that i didn't really
want to be somebody that's going to
look for grant money my entire career
and be in that academic world it was
just i liked more hands-on stuff so i
applied to the ucla school of public
health got my master's in public health
there
and then started managing ob gyn clinics
in westwood
in california and that's when i decided
i want to go to medical school so i
applied to medical school you know went
got a post back in biochemistry and
pre-medical sciences and i got into
medical school but in the mean during
that
four-year time of studying and taking
the mcat and all that
i saw you know because i was managing
these clinics for um
obgyn stuff i saw that i wasn't really
on board with the whole sort of western
way of looking at disease and illness
and symptoms and stuff like that so
i kind of became disillusioned so when i
got in
i just said forget it sorry sorry what
disillusion
disillusioned as in just treating the
symptom instead of the cause
or like what kind of disease yeah yeah
exactly yeah like looking at symptoms
uh not looking at underlying issues not
really
uh you know trying to resolve the
problem just looking at kind of
band-aiding things
so i decided not to go to medical school
my wife was from maui at the time
and we moved to back to hawaii
and i worked for the department of
health and i started doing sort of
therapy
type work with native hawaiian families
and i really really loved it so i
decided i want to get a doctorate in
psychology
so um after doing some sort of native
indigenous based
sort of uh sort of cultural appropriate
stuff with the hawaiian families
i took that sort of energy and brought
it to my to my dissertation and my
doctorate program
back in la and i worked on addiction
mostly
and i've worked with people that
struggle with all kinds of substance
issues
and i did my dissertation on uh native
hawaiian healing practices for addiction
so i've always kind of been in like an
indigenous
way to look at healing and underlying
stuff
and during grad school i managed a drug
and alcohol rehab that's pretty well
known
it's called passages malibu i was the
administrative director for about eight
years there
and when i was there i met a guy who
came in as a patient
and his name is jerry powell and he was
a
really rough guy super hardcore drug
addict
multi-millionaire dude somebody
it's hard to have leverage with because
it's kind of like what are you gonna
do like you know they have all these
homes and unlimited money
so yeah his life was crazy him and i
really hit it off though which was
interesting so
i was i didn't work with people at the
time because i was managing the facility
yeah but i i interviewed this guy and
i'm like
because i would always do a like a 40
minute intake
and i was like i can't turn this dude
over to my staff because he's just going
to just tear him up because he was very
difficult yeah
i decided to work with him myself yeah
so
i made an exception and worked with him
and we hit it off and he did really well
and he kicked his demerol habit that was
his main reason for being that
injectable demerol pain med and he was
addicted
he was using a lot of it so then he left
the program after 60 days
and then he kind of fell back into old
patterns
of behavior not with demerol he actually
got rid of that
but he was still doing cocaine and
drinking and womanizing and fighting and
he was just this
animal right and i was working with him
for about
five years i was doing some coaching i
was doing some
sort of counseling stuff with him in a
private practice environment
and i just couldn't get through to this
guy and there was something about him
that you know he was a very determined
person he was very driven
he really wanted to change but he just
didn't have the tools
was he was he heard about or or was he
like self-medicating or
what was going on he was partying he was
selling he was doing everything in the
book he was
like he had a lot of trauma that was
unknown at the time
like we looked at we looked at his past
and his you had a rough family grew up
in scranton pennsylvania
a coal town rough parents rough
dad his mom was wonderful his dad was a
little rough
a lot of abuse domestic violence that
kind of thing
and um so we would work on those issues
but
it was really hard to get to the core
sort of internal belief system and get
him to do
inner child work and kind of what's
needed to get past
trauma it was really hard for him so
on a whim he heard about some plant
medicine that was being offered in costa
rica
and he was becoming suicidal at the time
he'd been suicidal about three times in
his life you know so he was very
desperate
and he said you know what there's this
place in costa rica you he ran up by me
he's like you know they do plant
medicine i was like
dude you should definitely try it
because we've tried everything i've been
working with you for five years
we can't you know i don't know what else
to do so
he went by himself and he was there for
a week at this place up in the mountains
it was kind of a rustic
not a not a nice place it was somebody's
house you know it's kind of like how
plant medicine is
usually given you know aside from being
in the jungle it's just
kind of random places you know and
it totally changed his life he
completely flipped
and just did this 180. and i didn't
believe
him at first because i've never seen
anything like that happen
and i'm trained in the western medical
model and psychological model i'm a
psychologist doctor level
person and i don't have uh any sort of
case history
on people just doing a 180 like that so
quickly so
when i talked to him i went over to his
house you know he got back
i saw there was something really
different with this guy and his vibe was
different
all of his behaviors that he was doing
the self-destructive stuff the drugs the
alcohol the partying
all that just stopped it was crazy
and he told me you know that he wanted
me to go down there and do it i was like
very hesitant because i didn't have any
i'm not an addict you know in in my
doctorate program for psych
as i'm sure you know you have to do your
own you have to receive therapy yourself
about 65 hours
so i've been there i didn't know that
and i
yeah like to get licensed in in at least
in the u.s
uh psychologists have to go you know
they're when they're post-doctoral
students they have to get 65
hours of individual therapy for
themselves so you know i've been working
on stuff i knew who i was you know
pretty much
i didn't have some sort of glaring issue
that i thought at least
yeah so i said fine i'll go down there
and do it so he came with me we went
down a couple weeks later
i was really scared you know i'd never
done any psychedelics i've never done
any i've never done mushrooms i'd never
done lsd
yeah i wasn't a party or you know i was
it was a new
territory for me so i was pretty nervous
and but but i'd seen his results so i
thought well you know
can't be bad so i did it and what i
realized
was just the most amazing groundbreaking
stuff for me that
in my life it was the most amazing
experience it it showed me why
i was behaving the way that i was in
relationships
why i didn't trust people why i had all
these things and it was like crystal
clear
as day why and it was one night
and i thought this was like 20 years of
therapy in a night
i was blown away completely blown away
by it and that's where
jerry and i decided that we wanted to
have a place that was
really really safe for people and had a
lot of integration
had a lot of medical support and we
could screen people and
have a place that people could come to
that wasn't some
crappy house out in the middle of
nowhere you know
it was very expensive by the place like
2 000 bucks a night was very expensive
and so that's how that started and i've
been i moved to costa rica
within six months after that and i've
been there ever since so that was about
almost six years ago so i've been there
and
wrote the license with the government
and jerry was helping me of course doing
it and jerry's the business guy
the ceo of rhythmia and we just
developed this company and now we've
just been booming for the last you know
five and a half years wow
that's that's a very interesting story
um yeah i've dealt
i've delved into hallucinogens a bit
myself
um i started with like lower doses and
i've done i've never done an ayahuasca
i've done pretty high doses of shrooms
and found those experiences i had one
experience that was completely
transformative and that was like eight
grams
um so i've been wow really yeah it was
wow it was intense i went to outer space
yeah but
um i've been looking into ayahuasca and
so i thought we could
for this conversation i can just throw a
whole bunch of questions at you
um i grabbed i grabbed some questions
from my audience
so i figured that's like a good place to
start um
but but like first of all like some of
the easier questions what
does an experience kind of look like
like a ayahuasca is a drink right
correct yeah it's a it's a drink of it's
comply composed of two plants
one of the plants is a vine and that's
what people call the ayahuasca vine or
the plant of ayahuasca
it's a monoamine oxidase inhibitor so an
maoi
is very important because it turns off
in a sense the stomach enzymes
so that the other plant that's blended
in which is the dimethyltryptamine
that plant that has that can get
absorbed into the body so
and then if those two plants are reduced
down and there's it's
like a like a t and so you drink that
exactly
yeah and so this is like is it like an
extended dmt
trip yeah like different people
well the part that's similar about like
when people smoke
dmt it's very intense right it's very
quick
and it's it doesn't last too long
depends how much they smoke five minutes
to 30 minutes
very very very intense ayahuasca
is much more gradual once you drink
a dose you slowly build after about 45
minutes
into that space for a short period
and then it starts to decline so what
that means is that probably for like
maybe
30 minutes you're in this place that's
very uh you know connected and visual
and a lot of these things are happening
for people but it's not as intense as
like when people smoke bmt
and it allows more of an integration to
occur because it is slower
okay that's actually good to know so it
doesn't just hit you and
either there's an up and a down exactly
okay what about these are questions
these are questions i have first and
then i'll get to audience questions but
um does everybody get sick when they
take ayahuasca
no not everybody does and there's a
couple
sort of reasons for that i would say
about 50
of our guests get sick at least once
during their week there
and uh there's a thing called the dieta
and the dieta is sort of a shamanic way
to prepare for ayahuasca it involves
ways of eating
it's just eating clean healthy way and
also
behaving so usually uh not not having
sex for example for
as long as possible before a couple
weeks before month before
and not uh not drinking alcohol stuff
like that
there's a way to prepare so that when
you drink ayahuasca
and you follow the dieta there's less of
this sort of internal sort of
detox that happens because your already
body is already really clean and people
are less
purgative sometimes on that now a purge
is actually very important because it
has an emotional component that's being
released
so getting sick is actually a good thing
in a sense um it's not pleasant
obviously but
it's something that probably happens
about 50 of the people
okay that's interesting yeah i've never
had like from i've done
different forms of hallucinogens a
number of times and i've never had like
a purely
good time so like it's always been
absolutely fascinating and sometimes
transformative and i've had
a couple of like bad trips that i would
have rather avoided
but there it's never been you know it's
never been fun right it's not like
alcohol or something
correct it's a lot of work for sure oh
my god yeah
um okay so then how about this so you
offer it four nights in a row or four
days in a row
yeah four nights in a row okay and then
isn't it because i know with other types
of hallucinogens if you take it
repeatedly
um they don't work as well like the
following times so is that how ayahuasca
works as well correct
uh not not with ayahuasca because what
happens is with substances
generally since i have like this
addiction background right running
places and stuff
um most substances you need more of them
over time to get the same experience
right
or a heightened vibe with ayahuasca over
time you need less
and so it works the opposite so
night one people drink a certain amount
night two
they usually need less because their
body is cleared out their emotional
state
is more clear they've released a lot of
baggage
and so now they're more clear and then
they drink a little bit they can go less
and lighter and lighter
so we see at least in our four-day
you know consecutive nights it's like
monday night we start and we end on
thursday night the last one
we see that people have this amazing
transformation
and friday and saturday and sunday they
just chill they do breath work actually
they do
arithmetic breath work that we have so
there's other things to do but
it's we see that it's very powerful very
effective we have different
themes on each night and we help the
guests set certain intentions
that sort of match the theme of the
night so they get the most out of it
wow okay um
let me grab some of the questions that
people asked
okay do you know anything about
hallucinogens
changing like do you think that
hallucinogens are used
um as a therapy like a cell therapy or
do they actually change the brain
well i believe in synaptic plasticity of
the brain yes the brain can
shift and change right so um it depends
on the person
everybody's a little different depends
on what their intentions are it also
depends on their history of trauma
or what they're dealing with as a
neurochemical profile
so if we're just going to talk about
like the general sort of person
that you know let's say you know has a
an average amount of stress
or a couple of things they're trying to
work on or whatever
what we see is there's a release of
stored up emotion that's been sort of
handled in the amygdala part of the
brain
and the amygdala is where we store most
of our subconscious memories and
emotions
and so what happens when you drink
ayahuasca is that part of the brain
opens up and connects to the prefrontal
cortex
and then there's new neuron pathways
that become established
and so there's sort of like this
awareness vibe that occurs
and there's a serotonin experience it's
very very key
it helps with physical issues whether
it's pain management
and and also immunity and reducing of
swelling there's all this stuff that's
happening
and and also an emotional release that's
occurring
so uh a lot depends on the hallucinogen
but what ayahuasca does
is it absolutely creates new neuron
pathways
and it resets five key serotonin
receptors
wow okay so that's part of the reason
why some people can have such good
experiences regarding depression huh
um absolutely that's interesting um can
you
get similar do you think ayahuasca
is unique by itself or can you get
similar therapeutic benefits from
high doses or other doses of other types
of hallucinogens
i think that uh each each plant medicine
is unique in its own sort of way and
what it's intended to do or what it
brings forth
i think that ayahuasca the the clearest
maybe the closest thing to it would be
psilocybin
i believe yeah they're very different
you know psilocybin
is as you know is kind of like you're on
it you're on it and you can have this
dissociative experience that's
really helpful they kind of you get out
of your own way and you can kind of see
things different perspectives
ayahuasca has that same component to it
in the sense that
you can dissociate in a healthy manner
and then you can
see a new perspective on your life and
why it's happening
the reasons why it happens
neurochemically is very different
and the emotional sort of spiritual side
of it
is different they're both great
medicines but i think ayahuasca is
unique in the sense that it's very
uh it's very heart grounding
and there's a lot of like this shocker
stuff that i've learned
you know i'm not that's not one of my
fields of expertise but
i've learned from these shamans like
about all that kind of stuff
and it's very uh grounding for people
and healing
as as a as a remedy okay
interesting um so there are a lot of
people
i know a lot of people who haven't done
hallucinations before it's
scary the first time and no wonder like
because sometimes those high doses like
that
is insane you cannot imagine what that's
like until you do it
yeah um have you seen people have bad
experiences like bad
trips um and have that still be positive
in the end
absolutely yes we have and which is is
kind of rough to
to like say to people but yeah yes and
the thing about it is you know if you if
people go off into the into the jungle
with an
unknown place and the unknown shaman
they tend to
be given a lot of medicine and that can
be scary and for some people especially
those who've never done it before
yeah what we do is we start off with
about an ounce and a half or two ounces
of plant medicine which is very
little so we start off people gently and
then an hour and a half later
we give them another ounce and a half or
two ounces it's a good idea
yeah definitely so that's how people can
ease into the process
and they can kind of understand the
medicine a bit and guide it
to some degree so that's we do that
every night so we start off with that
small amount and they can ease into it
now sometimes
people have a high tolerance you know
they have a lot they're trying to work
on
they know this after the first night so
we'll double dose them
tuesday start off with a double so you
know we kind of manage each person by
the way they all get prescribed this by
our medical director
so the ministry of health requires us to
write a prescription
for ayahuasca to each person and so
that's how we do this so
we're monitoring how everybody's doing
and
and staying on top of like what dose is
working for each person so
for those that are afraid of it it's
understandable like i was terrified
but we ease you in which is which is a
nice way to do it
yeah that's that that's actually really
good to know um
that the times i've done high doses of
mushrooms i've started with
you know still not a low dose but i've
started with like three grams
see how that goes for a little bit and
then maybe 45 minutes and
take a larger amount and that seems to
be there's like a lot less panic
associated with that if i'm in a panicky
mood
so that's that's really good to know you
know what you were mentioning too about
like
if i've seen people have a bad like a
sort of a bad trip
yeah it ends up being a good thing the
way that i frame that because i do
sessions with people all week that are
struggling a bit that have had a scary
experience or something that's confusing
to them
and what it is basically in a nutshell
is that if i have a bunch of
trauma that i have never processed and
it surfaces and it's from childhood
let's say
it's it's hard to have a context for
fear and anger and resentment and guilt
and shame
in my 40s and 50s because i'm in a fine
place now
so those emotions when they are from
childhood when they surface
they're very confusing so what happens
is the prefrontal cortex will give a
context
to those emotions and try to help them
process out so if let's say i was abused
as a kid
sexually well i'm gonna have some fear
and some anger
right that's gonna come up and what's
what's what am i afraid of and what am i
angry about
i don't know maybe spiders or maybe uh
snakes or maybe a demon or something
that's a vehicle
that my brain will help create to get
those emotions to leave me
and to go so people that do have those
sort of experiences
are scared in the moment for a bit but
then when i talk with them and our staff
talks with them they understand like
okay that
was the vehicle to help just all leave
me you know
yeah interesting that makes sense
um okay let's see
oh yeah risks so like like i said there
are a lot of people are concerned
about this and no wonder um but are
there risks
of death or overdose can you overdose on
ayahuasca
people that are taking uh monoamine or
i'm sorry
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors
which are antidepressant
syndrome they're not yeah they're not
able to do ayahuasca if they're
currently
on those meds for serotonin syndrome can
occur
so we have to have people paper off
those meds with the help of their
physician
and then if you have 30 days free and
clear of those meds they can do
ayahuasca
if they're if they pass our physical
exam there's a lot of meds like that
that you got to have some time off of
whether it's benzodiazepines ssris
opiates and the adderalls and the dexa
dreams and all the stimulants
those two you have to be off that stuff
so also heart conditions if people have
a history of
heart surgery they have spins they've
maybe had a stroke in the past
there's certain gastrointestinal issues
that we look at so all of our
guests are screened before they even get
to rhythmia
and they talk to our intake staff and
they run it by us and all the medical
team
and then if we clear them then they come
and then we check them again we triage
them
we do an evaluation i interview about a
third of the people we have other staff
interviewing so uh now can people
overdose
we've never seen that happen we've never
seen anybody that's medically
appropriate
have a problem with the quantity
not once at our facility um most of the
risks
uh of ayahuasca that are out there in
the world if you think about okay
this person was injured or damaged or
hurt what happened it's people that are
nearby that are in the same ceremony
that become violent and hurt that person
that's the number one cause of
injury the other condition the other
number two
is that people choke on their vomit
that's the other
condition so that's again that just go
that's never happened in our place
nothing like that but that's why we have
a huge staff
to guest ratio and we're watching the
guests constantly
we have a huge amount of staff during
the ceremony so the risks are
are low when it's done safely
yeah okay that makes sense um what do
you do for people who do end up having a
bad trip and start freaking out
like what do you do with those guys well
sometimes if people have
already in them a high level of
serotonin naturally
which would be oftentimes considered a
bipolar one situation
um and sometimes people have bipolar one
and they're un they're undiagnosed like
they don't even know they have it
so when people do have a bipolar one and
we know about it we don't let them
usually drink medicine we usually say
that's not going to be a good method for
them at least
ayahuasca but let's say that they do and
let's say they come in they don't know
it we don't know
they don't have any history of that if
they do have a moment where they're in a
manic
sort of episode as a result because
that's what would happen
is they just become manic behaviorally
then we don't let them drink any more
plant medicine
and there's certain meds which we don't
like to use meds but there's certain
meds that will bring down the serotonin
within a couple days and then they're
back to normal they're fine
so people that have severe mental
illness or high risk
and those people aren't somebody that
we're recommending ayahuasca for
okay so i've got a fairly large audience
of people who
probably might be the type of person you
turn away
like um i deal with a lot of people with
autoimmune disorders and
mental disorders like i myself had
bipolar type 2
which i've managed to get under control
with diet and i've found hallucinogens
have been incredibly
helpful um once i was more stable
like that's something i could tell
people about too is when i was
on ssris and when i was having serious
mood problems
there were a number of times i tried uh
hallucinogens and it was
basically just stressful like it wasn't
until
my mood was a little bit better and more
stable that i found um a lot of benefits
of doing them
so what what about people with
autoimmune disorders
or people who are trying to solve like
idiopathic disorders do you see a lot of
those guys
we have a huge amount of those people
that come and ayahuasca is great for
that and the reason is because
as we know right t cells that are part
of our immune system
have serotonin receptors and when
somebody drinks ayahuasca serotonin is
affected in a positive way
and also dmt looks a lot like serotonin
if you look at the organic structure
they look very very similar and so
there's a huge reduction of inflammation
when people
drink ayahuasca so people have crohn's
disease
or rheumatoid arthritis or lupus
or any of these things they all come to
rhythmia and they all report
having a reduction in symptoms and we as
a medical facility can't make medical
claims
but we can definitely say what our
guests are telling us and what our
alumni have reported
and they they were experienced amazing
results
based on any sort of autoimmune
condition that they might have had so
they're good candidates for ayahuasca
okay interesting so autoimmune disorders
um people who are not currently taking
medications but maybe have substance
abuse problems
um that seems to be people you focus on
as well and the people who
maybe need to be careful about this are
people who are prone to mania
and psychosis right schizophrenia you
might want to
be careful with taking more
hallucinations
bipolar 2 is actually totally okay with
us
to come um bipolar 1 is the condition
that we have
yeah exactly we have to be careful with
bipolar one
okay okay so it's yeah so depression
then you see a lot of people with
depression
but less so with me yes okay correct
correct okay um so some people
are saying they suffer from depression
or anxiety very high in neuroticism
um and so some of these people react
badly to cannabis
is that someone that should be careful
around ayahuasca
no no they're very different um what we
recommend if people
are for example the people that you're
saying are probably not using cannabis
because they don't they don't have a
good experience
but if some people are using cannabis as
a plant medicine
we recommend they stay off of it for 30
days and
that just helps the person have a more
clean experience but
um if somebody has an issue with
cannabis it doesn't
correlate over to ayahuasca it's it's
totally okay
okay interesting and then um this is
just a question for me
um i know some people who are prone to
schizophrenia like that hits
you know particularly males in their
late teens right
and sometimes that can be increased with
cannabis use
is that something that people have to be
worried about with ayahuasca
not with ayahuasca and the reason is
because of the way
that the neurochemical response is
occurring
in the in the body and in the brain
people that have a predisposition to
schizophrenia
whether it's a family bloodline or
there's something going on
things that that cause stimulant effects
like sativa cannabis for example
and also uh crystal meth
cocaine and all the the stimulant
medications
those are things that can kick start a
schizophrenic episode and can kind of
like push a person to have that
occur ayahuasca is considered a
depressant
and it's not something that leads a
person into schizophrenia or kick-starts
them in that way
so that's that's really good obviously
interesting no
that is really good yeah um okay what's
the what's the average age
two questions what's the average age of
people who come visit you and
is there an age limit
we take anybody from 18 years old and up
and we've had people in their 90s come
and do really well there's no age limit
yeah there was a 96 year old woman who
came and she loved it so much that she
extended another week and stayed it came
again a year later i mean oh that's
amazing
yeah she was great so um our average age
is in the mid 40s to early 50s
but we've had 18 year olds there we've
had every age and you know group there
is but our average age is like 40s and
50s
plenty of 30 year olds plenty of 20 year
olds you know
70 year olds but our right in the middle
group is 40 late 40s early 50s
okay cool um do people generally come by
themselves or do you
recommend coming with somebody is there
a better way to do this
let's say uh let's say somebody's having
a couples issues
in their marriage or their relationship
we recommend
uh that they come by themselves first
really
and then come as a couple yeah um now
we've seen people come
as a couple and do great but uh what
tends to happen if you come as a couple
is you go oh okay i'm worried about my
partner or
you know i'm trying to figure out what's
going on with them and i don't worry
about or focus on myself that's kind of
a natural thing
so if people come as a couple which they
do all the time and it's totally okay
we just usually have them separate
during a plant medicine session so
they're on opposite sides of the room
that actually that actually does make a
lot of sense yeah that actually does
make a lot of sense if you're trying to
work through your own issues you don't
have to be worrying about how the other
person's doing the whole time
absolutely so a lot of people come by
themselves and a lot of women come by
themselves
and it's costa rica's really safe place
and we pick you up at the airport i mean
just
super super safe so it's totally okay to
come alone
okay cool um do people like what's the
living situation like how does that work
so we have three we have three different
kinds of rooms with different price
points
some people want their own room by
themselves a king room
and that's they have that and they just
have their own space their own bathroom
their own rooms like you know we look
like a resort because we were we were a
hotel that we purchased and converted it
into a medical facility
so there's all these bungalows
everywhere
and there's uh king rooms and there's
double queen
rooms and people sometimes come with
friends and they share a double queen
room
and then we have triple rooms for people
it's a lower price
you know we're working on some a bunch
of more singles that are in the
the triple price range we're expanding
you know and we're having more rooms
available so
it's really really nice resort and it's
like it's beautiful it's by the beach
it's right here at jw marriott in costa
rica northern pacific side
nice you know it's you could bike to the
ocean it's beautiful yeah it's a great
facility
so how long does an ayahuasca trip last
like what time do you start and how
when do people go to bed eventually
on monday tuesday wednesday we start at
5 30 in the
afternoon and right around one in the
morning it's done
and then we pick people up and walk them
back all the staff drives and the golf
carts everybody takes them back
and if people need to uh they're still
in their process they can stay in the
space
and we have staff that sit with them and
it's usually over by about one
now thursday night is a more of a
traditional colombian ceremony
so we start later 7 30 in the evening
and it goes until the morning the next
day around eight or nine in the morning
that's
the grand finale you know wow that
sounds that sounds fascinating
um i've so that's kind of similar to
shrooms then the length of
the length of trip depending on the dose
okay
if somebody drank one drink and they and
they just they didn't do this
because we offer four times a night to
drink
if somebody just drank one time it would
only last
about two hours oh wow or less
yeah okay i don't know half life is
short yeah dmt half-life is very short
so because people are drinking two times
or three times sometimes
four times that's why it extends out
until about one in the morning
for most people so if you're not if
you're not having a good time
and you drink it once then you can just
take that night off
correct oh well that's really good to
know because with shrooms you can't
really take any time off once you do it
you're when you're in it you're in it
yeah yeah you're kinda in it
um yeah let's see
um so a lot of people here have heard
about ayahuasca retreats in peru
i got a bunch of messages about that and
they're wondering if they're
if they don't have a lot of money how is
it that they can afford something like
this
if they go to the rhythmia website
right away comes up a window of a
scholarship application
so they can come for free so we offer a
ton of scholarships
yeah and uh you know other places are
are more affordable like in the jungles
of peru absolutely
um those those ten there's great ones
but there's a lot that are a little
sketchy and people don't really know
what they're kind of walking into
but again it's affordable so it's it's
inviting in that sense
so i would recommend just filling out an
application with us
because everybody that wants to come to
rhythmia will eventually be able to come
that's our goal
great that's great that's a great goal
for your average person with a strong
constitution
yeah okay so average person doesn't have
maybe maybe like yourself like you
weren't dealing with anything
obvious anyway uh dramatically obvious
uh how
often do unpleasant trips occur
well for me
i've done i've done it a lot obviously
but how many times how many times do you
think you've done it
i've done it probably 60 plus
times okay 60 70 times um
but i believe that the first 10 or 12
times that i did it
i got most of what i needed i was doing
it afterwards
um to kind of test out different
medicines and
kind of get a vibe for what we were
going to present and offer to the guests
so my own therapeutic process was about
10 or 12
ayahuasca ceremonies and i personally
never had any bad ones in there
but i do see i'd say probably
maybe five to ten percent of our guests
might have
a scary night or a scary moment and
it's it's something that is very
therapeutically beneficial so
um i haven't seen anybody at our
facility
have something that was devastating to
them
you know it's it's it's all about the
context that we help them have
with the integration that occurs during
the day time
for them afterwards yeah that's really
important
um the only time i've ever had like i've
never had a
catastrophic trip but the only time i've
had one that was
i was uncomfortable in it i was
panicking a bit and was like am i
well what's going on like i find people
who have bad trips sometimes they feel
like they can't breathe and things
and so i knew i was having a bad trip
when i was having it
um but i still got some of the benefits
afterwards so i'm wondering if ayahuasca
does this as well
is i find this sense of calm
like serious calm and mood stability
regardless of how the trip went
for you know up one day to maybe a week
after does iowa could give you that as
well
yeah but what we're seeing because we're
sending out um
surveys when people leave we're sending
out a 10-day survey
and a three-month survey and a six-month
survey what we're seeing
is that people are 98 of the guests are
still in the zone
and so we have these incredible
statistics that we keep we keep a ton of
data
we have about 130 000 data points
that we're compiling with what we're
offering to the guests so
that vibe if people are still doing
healthy stuff for them you know
afterwards eating right
having a daily practice trying to make
the right decisions for themselves
it can continue indefinitely which is
really exciting
and kind of hard to believe because most
stuff is not like that
you know now that sort of pink cloud
like that we call an addiction the pink
cloud where everybody's so happy and
excited
they feel sober and they're great uh
that lasts for several months afterwards
that
really excited space it's really cool
that's that's really fascinating i went
to a talk with
um dennis mckenna and my husband and
this was before my husband
had done uh any type of hallucinogen and
um again i was talking about how this
can be a completely transformative
experience and it's unlike anything
anyone's experienced
and andre's my husband was just like you
know
scoffed he scoffed and i was like
this is like we'll see how you feel
about this in a couple of weeks
but yeah it is it it's it's an i like i
said i haven't done ayahuasca i want to
i will
but um hallucinogens are definitely an
experience
that i would say i recommend to most
people there it's
unbel it's unbelievable you can't
imagine it's like seeing a new color
right it's more than that yeah it's
incredible
well i just think that most
hallucinogens like i was saying earlier
when we were discussing this is that you
kind of just get out of your own way
and you see things from a different
perspective and sometimes
right we're sitting we're sitting in our
emotions that can be
overwhelming and we know intellectually
what to do
but we just can't get the emotional
energy to do it
and plant medicine helps us in all these
different
ways help us kind of like get past that
you know so that's the the healing
in it it's just wonderful to see
yeah yeah it's incredible i felt like
the lot the last
uh last experience i had i felt like it
was reality that i'm
experiencing now is kind of like on the
hallucinogen it was like a band-aid been
torn off
it just showed me it like everything
that i
didn't like i kind of knew but didn't
really want to know and like you said
earlier
it showed me how i was contributing this
was rough how i was contributing
negatively to
every relationship in my life it was
like these are the little like pokey
things you say
or like how you kind of undermine this
other person i was just like
oh my god that was like a slap in the
face
it's a lot yeah what what what people
are also
you know not used to having if they do
hallucinogens they're not used to having
a team of
people right there to help them process
and talk through what's going on
so if i have a bad trip i'm in my living
room
and i got just my buddies everybody
leaves the next day well i'm just
freaked out and i'm confused and scared
and they just move on and it was just it
was a horrible night
but that's not what's going on at our
place because people that have a
so-called bad trip
learn what it means and learn about it
and they sit with us and we talk to them
we do
therapy right and there's all this
support so when people leave they're not
like
thinking oh that was a bad trip like wow
that was very impactful i needed to see
that
that was very important for my life um
that's good yeah because
the the things i think that have been
stopping me from going to a place like
rhythmia
is i'm i'm fairly extroverted but i
don't necessarily
i'm not particularly comfortable around
strangers so what stopped me was well i
don't
necessarily want to be around strangers
when i'm doing something that's as
intimate as
like a hallucinogenic trip so that's
that's one of the things
sure um but it is good to be able to
talk to people about it
that really helps it is
and you know the way we run the facility
because all the guests have such
different needs you know they all come
from different backgrounds they come
from all over the world
i mean we have people from dubai from
all over
asia u.s canada i mean latin america we
have people from everywhere
come all over europe and there's
cultural
uh beliefs and there's also social
sort of norms that are different for
everybody and sometimes we gotta have a
place
off to the side for a guest you know
during the the plant medicine session
where they can feel safe and comfortable
or maybe we have a woman that's been
through a lot of trauma from men
and we don't want her laying right next
to a guy to a man
you know we want to have her off by the
side maybe with some other supportive
women or just by herself or whatever so
we adjust the program in a sense to kind
of meet the needs of that individual
client which is a client-centered client
based approach that we take
that i brought that sort of approach
back from you know all of my therapy
years
you know doing client-centered therapy
yeah i like that and
i guess the other benefit is you get to
meet people who are open to this kind of
thing and are probably
fascinating so it's one benefit from
doing it with a number of other people
yeah
um so then i guess
what would another question um what's
the difference do you think between
having i mean you went into it a bit but
between having a guide and not having a
guide on some of these trips
well i think if somebody now with
ayahuasca
right there's there's shamans around and
all these assistants and helpers
and they're providing a safe space but
they're not really
guiding you guiding is more
related to other plant medicines like
iboga and iboga
definitely has a guide it's somebody a
shaman
talking to you and giving you context in
the moment
and going to detail with you now
ayahuasca
there is a there can be a bit of a
guidance vibe if somebody is
confused or struggling they raise their
hand they go hey i'm tripping on this i
don't understand
is all this stuff happening then the
shamans will help sort of guide them a
bit
and move energy through and out of the
space so
i think the important thing is that if
people are not guided or don't
have a safe space and you know i grew up
in l.a
and in venice california they're doing
plant met you know you like watch all
the times yeah
and it's it's real sketchy it's real
sketchy because there's no guidance
there's no support
it's a bunch of people in a garage or a
basement it's really
it's not good in my opinion because if
you're going to be working with people
energetically and also spiritually
and also emotionally you really got to
know what you're doing
and it takes a lot of training and a lot
of sort of it's like a calling
right like as psychologists we don't
just it's we didn't just fall into this
career as psychologists like we
have a knack for it it's what we're
interested in right yeah i mean i know
you know all about that field too right
so
it's kind of like having a guided
experience is very important for safety
for emotional spiritual safety
okay that makes sense that's um do you
guys do do you guys do more plant
medicine or is it mainly ayahuasca
i initially had us licensed for san
pedro
and uh we used to do san pedro in the
mornings which is a cactus
and it's similar actually have you not
heard of that
i feel like i've heard of a lot of
things and i've not heard of that
it's similar to peyote but it's not as
strong as peyote
peyote is much more psychedelic
and much more visual so it's uh it's a
daytime plant medicine
and it's uh it's a masculine plant
medicine whereas ayahuasca is more of a
feminine
energy and we used to do those in the
mornings
so ayahuasca at night san pedro in the
morning but what we were seeing
we were seeing that some people just
were not able to function
you know in the in the supportive groups
and classes that we had so
we we pulled it but that's that's we
also do rape
if you're a rappe i have heard of rape
can you fill me in again on exactly what
that is
rape is a shamanic snuff
so it's like a it's a powder made in
these indigenous
tribes and it's it's got mostly uh it's
got some tobacco
but also has a lot of herbs again a
regional
based on the tribe that's making it so
it can have up to 50 or more herbs or
or fewer depending on the tribe and it's
administered by a shaman
up the nose like a little blow like a
little little spray
and what that does is it aligns the
chakras and gets people grounded
and helps people open up and there's all
these millions of different kinds of
rape
but the ones that we use help people get
centered and more receptive to
the ayahuasca so we do that right at the
beginning of each
session and then if guests are sort of
stuck or not you know they're coming out
of the vibe
they can also get it during the during
this session as well
um so your shamans the people who are
helping uh how did you manage to find
those guys
that was not easy that was
probably the hardest thing i've done as
the as the administrator there
so we have a guy his name is taito
juanito and he's from
uh a colombian indigenous tribe and he's
an ayahuasca bloodline guy
lives up to amazon river you know he's
comes out once in a while
oh yeah that's good i can see how that
could be hard to convince somebody like
that hey
can you come help us in what we're doing
or like who are you
wasn't easy so uh we were able to
and he comes four times a year and
has hosts a week-long thing with us
and then he's trained a lot of these
other shamans he has a whole team of
them
some have been with them for 30 years
and i've been with them for one year
so it's all different zones of guys
trained by him
and uh so we have all these different
types of
guys and women too men and women who
have been trained
and who who administer the plant
medicine
in the evenings so uh
we have a lot of helpers too they're not
quote unquote shamans so we have about
we have like a nine to one ratio so nine
guests and there's at least one staff
or more that's our minimum ratio these
are just higher ratio than that so
more more staff than that so they're
they're they're interesting
people you know yeah yeah wow coming
from a western thing
you know medical background that i have
i'm like talking to these guys and you
know
they have a different way of looking
everything which is wonderful i mean
i've learned so much from them
they're really cool fun people yeah the
interesting thing about that is
our way is most definitely not
necessarily the most right way
especially in regards to pharmaceuticals
i've had some like i'm not really happy
with pharmaceutical companies at the
moment
i'm with you i'm with you yeah uh
okay then i think the last question is i
i had a couple people ask
can if they wanted to organize a group
of people to come themselves can you do
private more private events at rhythmia
uh yeah we can and we're in part of our
expansion that we're doing
is uh gonna be able to accommodate
exactly that
so um we can definitely talk to people
that want to have
private events and different groups and
smaller groups or whatever
absolutely what our data shows just as
an interesting side note
the larger the group the more successful
is our outcome data and that's very
counterintuitive
because if i if i was with a shaman with
five people i would think right that i'm
gonna get what i need
but what we're seeing with the data is
that
the more people in involved in a
ceremony the higher
like the synergy of the group is that it
kind of propels and helps
move people yeah it's really interesting
that's a statistic that i did not expect
but we have data to prove that aside
from that
yes we definitely can work with groups
and have certain situations occur where
they can bring a group of people and
you know we can absolutely talk about
that for sure
okay okay so then this is my last
question i think um so just for
logistics do people people go to your
website
and buy a plane ticket to costa rica
they get picked up at the airport
and it's about a week-long thing unless
you want to extend it that's how it
works
correct yeah and they they show up on
saturday or sunday
those are check-in days so yeah they go
to their website
they call our 800 number they talk to a
representative we ask them a bunch of
medical questions if there's
uncertainty then they get a hold of me
and our medical director we go over the
medical notes
then we clear them then they show up
they get their own flight to liberia
costa rica which is the northern airport
in costa rica we pick them up
it's about a 45 minute to an hour drive
bring them to our place
they're there for a week they leave on
the following saturday or sunday
everything's included all the
farm-to-table food
all the massage we have a spa beautiful
beautiful spa like a five-star spa
and massages and there's a pool and it's
beautiful and then go to the beach
and all that's included and then at the
end we take them back to the airport
we shuttle them back and they're off so
that's basically how that works wow
it sounds pretty good and people aren't
too exhausted the next day
to go do things about you know on
thursday
night which is the final ceremony that
goes until friday morning
yeah right after around maybe like noon
or 2 p.m
on friday they're they're good to go
they can go to the beach and
cruise around some people go ziplining
and do more touristy stuff
and then saturday if they leave some
people leave on sunday so on saturday
it's kind of a fun day
to go cruise around check out costa rica
a little bit
so yeah they have plenty of energy
because because they've taken a burden
off of them
right like they're there to release
emotional tension
so they feel like a million bucks yeah
clearer
right lighter um okay i had one
i had one more question am i gonna be
able to remember this
yeah okay okay so um part of my audience
follows well i'm kind of in the paleo
keto diet
carnivore diet area so a lot of my
followers
especially with autoimmune disorders are
on really ridiculously strict diets
is that going to be manageable
manageable for instance
i've only been eating beef for like
three years and that's it
um not quite three but a while so a lot
of these people have sensitivity serious
sensitivities to gluten and whatever and
they're gonna be quite worried about
diet when they're there
for sure we we absolutely can adjust
our diet and our our menu to accommodate
those
those guests our our menu
actually fits into all those scenarios
paleo
also high protein we don't serve uh beef
products there
but we can get them for sure because
costa rica is
awesome beef off amazing
okay cool not a problem not a problem
yeah not a problem so get in touch get
in touch if you have concerns get in
touch if
you can't afford to go but you feel like
you need it and i guess
um and maybe well the reason that you
put this together
it's to help people sort through issues
in a in a faster more beneficial way
that seems to me what you're going for
right
that's right because i was i was so
disillusioned
by the system that i was working in in
mental health and in oh yeah medical
health care
and this is something that actually
works for people and so
it's just something that we want to help
change the world with you know and
one person at a time and getting empathy
for others and
having empathy and love for yourself is
very important and we believe that's how
the world changes so that's
what we're out to do cool
well thank you very much for coming on
um i think people are going thanks for
having me
super interesting and yeah i would urge
anyone who's trying to sort out
like because you can have some serious
issues with your life and
as i very know well uh very well know
um covering those up with
pharmaceuticals
that i would not recommend that right
and this is a good way
and it sounds like a safe way to try and
get to the bottom of it with the
supportive community
so yeah thanks again for coming on i
appreciate it thank you so much for
having me i look forward to hopefully
meeting you down there and all your
guests all your
your viewers that'd be awesome yes yes i
will come down at some point
but cool i'll talk to you later
[Music]
you